you gotta teach me Japanese curse words
because I want to learn that's the first
thing you learn in the language hi I'm
ray hi i'm galleon last time I
challenged v8 to make a Dominican dish
solely in Spanish this time the tables
have turned
she's challenging me to make a Japanese
dish while she explained it to me in
Japanese hi da da to occupy static are
not spiritus within myself
so stay what I should have got here
donate nihongo this cut the audio see
report okay thank you my friend
this is not gonna be easy so they say
it's the ingredients okay I'm gonna give
you a little Japanese lesson so we can
go over ingredients in Japanese Unicode
tamanegi Tina's our jagai moaning Jean
Patou show you go MA a Buddha meeting
socket got it so this dish is Japanese
home cooking yeah something you don't
find a restaurant so this is like the
like when you're young this is like the
first dish you learn how to make yeah
yeah yeah okay
so where am I gonna spec so this is like
a soup we'll see
oh you know this I am a little nervous
you won't be I will give you instruction
okay
in Japanese I know ready
yes your mother sighs shiny thing what'd
she say
come on Iggy oh boy did it come on Iggy
come on Iggy grab the onion okay take
this all right yes humbly keep it there
cut it cut it Humber and have Wow
I did Google half okay okay we got this
we got this
no need to be nervous okay daddy L it's
simple and this is just cooking okay
yeah we are not saving world
Mean Gene Mean Gene Mean Gene
what about give me good yeah - guy mouse
named gene the guy mas cigars so that
ninja right-to-carry kono hey da da sake
I took the key to break it up there come
on what you must come with you must oh
yeah yeah yeah okay okay this is how you
do it haven't peeled anything that long
time do you cook at home I do by having
done a long time there we go we did it
hi Eugene or kitty must van GD 9 GD a
little circle icky icky icky icky in
Japanese sake is autumn like a season
for an angle yeah okay yeah he's called
the wrong giri it's not starting shape
it's kind of different
Oh your finger when you cut something
also like you want to hold like like
this like this yeah okay crawl so we
learn something together they're here
all right that's a geek jagai mo mu
Tomas is that the beef no this is the
potatoes anyone me to peel the potato hi
Japanese and Spanish sounds similar no
sense somewhat was somewhat my own is
always posting pictures of Mike a little
Japanese cousin singing they think
they're bachata artists what's bachata
my chat dies like is a Dominican music
winner one two three start one two three
stop three
stop there you go Hey my mom sees me
making a mess like this in her kitchen
she will kill me
sure but I get up and I'm in a park a
car Pluto which the exact translation is
I will throw you out the window
so you will land and explode
ha - I'm all Gibby mas Jack I'm on Kitty
massage okay yeah I'm okay team us with
Brees we're gonna cut it down or yes my
humble Nikita humble come on yeah Meetup
do you remember how to count a little
bit each evening
Sanchi go Lou hitch hatch Cujo yes yes I
did it I said I didn't Japanese Victor
Victor yes zucchini King Messiah King
Uzziah this right here hi Oh Antonia the
mother co-op there
Suzie Oh 20 months this is so cool
this reminds me of my country like the
pigeon peas they will wash your hand
wash it we pick out the bad ones the
rice whatever rice had the peels will
hand it would take it out one by one
yeah it's like sitting down the table
and with Grandma yes it reminds your
family this smells like home hi oh uh
yes io Denver Kitty already much stuff
hello yes I am us want to grab all this
and we want cookie so this ratio
Tomodachi agent pacci
ya ya komaru na come abre also chichi
either take it outside
I won't put water in there she got no
we're gonna turn this on together
Gomorrah
Kamara Kamara the oil yes
okay ha ha oh ha gee you're gonna put
the office also Gigi it's you are did
you do you remember Ichi which is one of
these ray no no it is isn't me
it eats Oh 81 yeah they're all Sergey
asaji okay so also cheats tables famous
poem so Monty was high nice that's a
Guinea come on easy
come on Iggy superb done in high you get
that put all of it hi Mean Gene Mean
Gene Mean Gene that stuff right oh good
job
Jack I want and the particular high Wow
I see yo Japan in Dominican Republic in
the house right okay so God yell let's
uh no your mother in my shop okay let's
turn this up hi hey we don't want the
bottom to burn them all right hi Thank
You Olga don't know Bob but uh Nicole
come on Vick to do okay keep stirring it
they really want to like mixing the the
onion the carrots and the potatoes right
right means a mixer
music water yes water it don't come
Decker some big high drag Arielle we've
got a light down there okay do you any
good
jenika which is the beef right hi hi
there mouth you're gonna do the whole
thing in there okay it's you - okay yeah
don't just drop it all in there it's a
my show pop this up so my concert is I
joke all right there's even like that
and zucchini forget the meeting with
Emma's okay so that's when we add the
sake hi sake also GT besides you need
I'm meeting all such you want me to put
this one so high oh you know what when I
was young that's at Saito karate cut out
there got out there yeah yeah martial
arts and stuff like that that was a kid
so I don't know man after the beach the
Sun tea go don't know why but that's how
they taught us I never fought in my life
in the street like hi Josh haha Sato so
let let it settle that means it's a toy
that means though what I do on my socks
it does that mean I put this
hi all sizing me hmm
so that's 200 you saw that yeah she said
it all in Japanese young and I listen
you sure you do you tell me this before
doing this right here
hi so you're all sides you got
oh sure you all sat see the three right
go each nice and oh no it's it's nice
Angie call five hi sorry there it starts
could amass it's origami time okay uh
Corday oh okay corner let's put this
corner right here I'm a [ __ ] bear
yeah I messed that up we did Mimi Corday
oh okay that's a long because you know
what this reminds me of Marie Kondo
right now why cuz she teaches you how to
fold and all that stuff now I fold my
clothes like she does so I'm like a
cookie money yeah you are free Coco Coco
so the whole thing I'm also gonna fold
it in half yeah
Simon it Kaleo Kippur Wow it took say
money we did it we did it we did it it's
like a paper plane so they're there
today all time up there Monica nice
I was it there poor kitty must keep that
so we're gonna clip want me to cut the
rest of it no no I mean I Tomas it's a
good lid bit cor they all does everybody
know this like how to do this like I'm
on at the culinary school this leader is
very useful when you're braising stuff
don't gotta jiggle hunger life he must
must go out July Monique he got all the
money
what'd she say Ben pretty much all team
this high up can I say yeah mmm
and then we're gonna drop this in there
hi yeah hi hi oh you've good in it
gentle gentle
what are they me sample example nays 1
no
son took 2 3 boom is Oh two to three
minutes yes and you are done God yell
okay oh wow
make you nice make a nice oh okay I got
it
mm-hmm so for more card Oh what's called
a dates - this is not the steel
yeah so I think this is enough sauce
it looks delicious door
I can tell you that yeah listen I'm
dying to try it out okay and I'm going
to bring mine and then we can compare my
god yay oh wow
why are yours better than mine that
taste is basically anything we're gonna
taste the same I think so you did a
great thank you yeah so you are dying to
know the neighborhood East Asian okay so
this dish named it's an equal jaga
nikujaga so nickel is meat jaga eats
potato so me and potato so let's try
mine first
yeah the game I didn't do it and also
this dish it's tastier next day but it's
like absorb all the nice flavor
interesting it's just like home mm-hmm
and let's try yours
all right I like yours better I think
it's because I made it yesterday I
wanted to teach you this because you
taught me oil grease a dog see it's very
homey food right yeah I do feel like I'm
at home I take a bite and I'm like I'm
accessible Japan right now no I'm saying
yeah you like it
are you gonna make it at home yeah God
yo it's gonna make a home he's gonna hug
me on Instagram if you do it please talk
to me on the Instagram God yell on my
Instagram do you want to finish with
dancing I'll just do it on one two three
[Music]